there are several political issues
brewing and for some perspective on all
of them we turn to ed O'Keefe he is a
congressional reporter for The
Washington Post and a CBS News
contributor at good morning I guess
let's start first with Roy Moore their
establishment Republicans have not been
a fan of collectively a fan of weary
more for a while now is there any
recourse at this point to get him off
the ballot or out of this there's really
not much that Republicans outside of
Alabama can do at this point to stop
more from remaining on the ballot
remaining a candidate and potentially
winning the election I mean at some
point if he were to win they might be
able to try censoring or expelling him
once he's seated but really beyond that
there's really nothing they can do it's
all in the hands of Alabama Republicans
who have given no indication at this
point that they plan to either ask him
to step down or encourage people to run
for somebody to vote for somebody else
if these allegations continue to hang
over him
is he a problem nationally for the party
if he's on the ticket the fact that
we're talking about him yes we're not
talking about tax reform and all the
other things that Republicans would
rather have us talk about proves that
he's a problem this is why they didn't
want him to be the candidate down there
to replace Jeff Sessions they've had
other issues with him you know the fact
that he's been expelled as the Chief
Justice of Alabama in the past but they
just you know he was not their choice
they dropped him faster than I expected
I mean that the story published and
within two hours they were saying if
this is true he should be gone that's
lightning fast for Republicans and we
talked about Rory Moore in the context
of the Senate balance of power
Republicans have a two seat majority
we're looking towards 2018 some big
Senate and House races coming up there
there were elections this week Democrats
feel emboldened how did you read the
victory is on Tuesday night what I think
it showed is that Democrats at least at
the local county and state levels are
figuring out how to talk about something
other than Donald Trump and take
advantage of the fact that people are
showing up to vote because they don't
like Donald Trump they're not making him
the central issue an exit polling in
both Virginia and New Jersey suggests
that he's not the main factor but you
saw candidates across the country talk
about the economy talk about health care
talk about job creation Democrats have
been say
for months and that's what we've got to
do it appears to have worked in Virginia
New Jersey and legislative races in
Georgia and Washington State mayoral
races across the country as well what's
your sense ed of how Republicans are
reading these results they would you
talk to them they'd like you to believe
that this was only confined to those
states fine to those states can find it
areas of those states where Hillary
Clinton prevailed yeah but the problem
is they lost statewide elections that
they had a good shot at winning when
when the campaign began especially in
Virginia and and a lot of these
Republican candidates were embracing
Trump's style tactics running ads that
raised concerns about undocumented
immigrants running ads that tried to
sort of attack and this rate the
Democratic opponent in ways that Hillary
Clinton was last year but because
they're not Donald Trump and they didn't
fully embrace Donald Trump it backfired
for them also just a divisive this was
rejected so they're gonna have to
rethink a lot of the ways that they run
campaigns in these states in these
suburban areas of the country where
Democrats made big gains and a lot of
Republicans think one of the things they
must do to hold on to their majority in
the Senate in the house is packs pass
tax reform we know that the House and
Senate have now unveiled their plans how
close are we to a deal actually getting
done well the plan is for the house to
pass their version the Senate to pass
their version probably right after
Thanksgiving if not right before and
then to see the two chambers come
together quickly put together an
agreement that the president can sign
before Christmas that's very very fast
it is
and remember they tried to do this with
health care over the summer it failed to
move quickly the the issue for them is
if they can't get it done by January you
bleed into an election year and there's
concerns about this just festering too
long but the goal in the house was to
get this done as quickly as possible
so that it didn't sit out there for
lobbying organizations and Democrats and
other groups to sort of start picking it
apart and saying wait you're gonna do
this you're gonna do that you're gonna
close this loophole but not that one and
that's part of the problem here the
other issue of course is you know what
extent will corporations get a tax break
when are they getting more favorable
treatment and individual tax payers all
those things you have to be sorted out
whether or not they can do it on that
timeline look they're tracker good this
year has been pretty bad so it's also a
several thousand page piece
legislation that will affect every
sector of the US economy a daunting task
ed O'Keefe keep telling us the good news
then great to see you